vous êtes sur france 24 vous avez raison
bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir la mort de
cinq gendarmes tués par des séparatistes
anglophones dans l'ouest du cameroun
l'attaqué a été revendiquée par un chef
milicien le pays vous savez traverse une
grave crise avec un conflit entre le
pouvoir central les zones anglophones et
depuis 2016 le pays déplore la mort de
plus de 4000 civils les explications de
notre correspondant dès le début de ce
journal
que se passe-t-il au togo les autorités
cherchent et elle a étouffé un mouvement
de contestation après les grèves de mars
dernier une centaine d'enseignants ont
été licenciés ou révoqué certains sont
même en prison reportage à suivre
et ils vous emmènerai à dakar pour
parler d'art thérapie en pleine biennale
des arts vous verrez certaines oeuvres
réalisées par des patients en hôpital
psychiatrique
on ouvre ce journal par cette attaque de
séparatistes anglophones dans l'ouest du
cameroun qui a causé la mort de cinq
gendarmes et fait deux blessés graves
l'attaqué a été revendiquée par un chef
milicien qui se fait appeler générale no
pity général sans pitié notre
correspondant marcel amouroux nous en
dit plus les assaillants venus en nombre
ont fait usage de lance roquettes d'obus
et de kalachnikovs le poste de
gendarmerie a même été incendiés le
bilan est lourd 5 gendarmes tués et une
dizaine de civils ont également été
enlevés une attaque revendiquée par le
chef milicien sécessionniste qui se fait
appeler générale no pity général à 110
kg est selon lui cette attaque est une
réponse à la mort de neuf civils tués le
1er juin dernier dans le département de
la menchum région anglophone du nord
ouest par l'armée à camlez une armée
camerounaise qu'avec d'ailleurs reconnu
une bavure ce n'est pas la première fois
que les séparatistes anglophone attaque
une ville en bordure de la région
anglophone du nord ouest et de la région
francophone de l'ouest une proximité qui
pourrait peut-être expliquer ces
incursion en mars 2020 hui éléments des
forces de défense et de sécurité
camerounaises avaient ainsi été tués
dans l'attaqué d'une gendarmerie et de
commissariats selon lui si international
4000 civils ont déjà été tués à la fois
par les forces de défense et de sécurité
camerounaises et les séparatistes armés
comme le font depuis la fin octobre 2016
le bilan des éléments des forces de
défense et de sécurité camerounaises
tués en zone anglophone reste lui
inconnu
c'est une zone devenue un sanctuaire de
djihadistes de boko haram et d'autres
groupes terroristes
ils sont désormais sous pression de la
force conjointe entre le cameroun le
nigeria le tchad et le niger plusieurs
centaines de terroristes ont été tués
par des opérations lancées fin mars si
sur le plan militaire c'est une victoire
qu'en est il du volet humain les
populations qui ont fui la région
attendent toujours de pouvoir rentrer
chez elle la correspondance à niamey
d'aral chira
805 terroristes abattus près de 70
véhicules brûlés plusieurs fabriques
d'engins explosifs improvisés
neutraliser et beaucoup de saisie de
munitions cette force conjointe est là
clairement regagner du terrain dans la
zone des îles du lac tchad face à son
adversaire cette avancée de la lutte
antiterroriste aux frontières l arrivée
elle correspond à des agendas politiques
d'abord ceux du niger puis ceux du
nigeria ici le président mohamed bazoum
veut redonner du souffle aux
réinstallation de population dans la
région de diffa comme il tente de le
faire dans la région de tillabéri où il
a dernièrement multiplié les visites du
côté du nigeria le gouvernement en place
à moins d'un an de l'élection
présidentielle veut se réaffirmer face à
ce qui est devenu le premier problème
des nigérians l'insécurité est l'une des
manières les plus visibles de le faire
c'est de ramener les populations
originaires du nord-est du nigeria chez
elle mais pour l'instant les conditions
ne sont pas réunies je me suis entretenu
plus tôt avec plusieurs représentants
d'organismes humanitaires internationaux
et tous s'accordent à dire que cette
victoire ne se transformera en victoire
durable que si les deux états le niger
et le nigeria dans les zones qui les
concernent s'accordent sur le fait qu'il
faut redonner des moyens à la police
mais aussi à la gendarmerie depuis 2009
et l'insurrection de boko haram c'est
plus de 36000 personnes qui ont été
tuées par le groupe terroriste
et cette mise au point faite sur notre
antenne du président du sénégal et en
exercice de l'union africaine après sa
visite en russie macky sall a tenu à
répondre à ceux qui lui reprochent de
soutenir la politique du président
vladimir poutine écoutez le au micro de
marc perelman il christophe boisbouvier
pour errer fille s'est fait un
communiqué avec le président l'a de la
commission de l'union africaine dans sa
fac un communiqué conjoint pauvre con à
l'intervention et exiger le respect de
la souveraineté de lui que cela ne veut
pas dire que je dois pas parler à la
russie lorsque je considère que le
marché est bloqué parce que d'une part
un des grands fournisseurs qu'ils
n'arrivent plus à exporter mon devoir
est le doigt des africains de
sensibiliser plaidant pour dean sur ce
fait demandé d'agir concert avec les
nations unies pour que cette comprendre
soit levée mais vous pourrez retrouver
l'intégralité de cet entretien sur
toutes nos plateformes
dont on passe au reste de l'actualité
africaine en bref et en images
la course contre la montre pour éviter
une famine en somalie est engagé les
nations unies tirent la sonnette
d'alarmé
deux cent mille personnes seraient
menacées dans un contexte de sécheresse
record au total plus de 7 millions de
personnes souffrent de faim soit la
moitié de la population du pays
cette affaire de cambriolage qui
embarrasse le président sud africain
cyril ramaphosa est accusé d'avoir
dissimulé à la police et au fisc un vol
dans une de ses propriétés au cours
duquel d'importantes sommes d'argent en
liquide ont été trouvés caché dans du
mobilier la médiatrice la république
notamment chargé entre autres de la
lutte contre la corruption a annoncé
mercredi l'ouverture d'une enquête
publique sur cette affaire de
cambriolage
après les regrets et non les excuses
formulées par le roi des belges en
visite à kinshasa au troisième jour de
visite en rdc et philippe de belgique a
rencontré jean jacques louis mbe figure
de la lutte contre le virus ebola
vendredi le couple royal se rendra à
lubumbashi avant de terminer par bukavu
dimanche où ils rencontreront un autre
docteur le prix nobel de la paix le
gynécologue denis mukwege gay
on passe à la grève des enseignants au
togo qui prend une tournure inquiétante
après le mouvement de contestation de
mars dernier une centaine d'enseignants
a été licencié ou révoqué ils sont huit
en prison les autorités leur reprochent
site des actes de cette incitation à la
violence de la désobéissance et de la
révolte de reportage d'emmanuelle
seigner
comme une centaine de ses collègues koku
mawuena a perdu son emploi d'enseignant
en avril dernier il est le secrétaire
général du syndicat des enseignants du
togo le 7 un syndicat déclarée illégale
par les pouvoirs publics les autorités
accusent le syndicat d'avoir organisé
des grèves sans base égale depuis 2020
ces résultats qui n'avaient pas voulu à
ce que en soir par l'asfa bf1 des cas où
tout est content il n'est pas dit que
c'est parce comme sont manipulés par
l'opposition que nous avons organisé ces
mouvements de grève en mars et avril
dernier le 7 prend la tête de la
contestation
en devenant le seul syndicat
d'enseignants à relancer les grèves
selon le syndicat contestataire l'état a
signé un accord avec les organisations
syndicales pour de meilleures conditions
de travail qui n'a pas été respecté tout
la fête d'activité fonds dynamique c'est
pas parce qu on a fini un accord en
avril
cela signifie que tous leurs problèmes
enfants règle est définitivement et
irrémédiablement à l'issue de ces
mouvements de protestation sept élèves
et trois enseignants sont toujours en
détention comme cosic aussi quand le
mari de dia tout numéro deux du syndicat
tous sont poursuivis pour troubles
aggravé à l'ordre public elle a vu une
fois depuis son arrestation et m'a dit
paulo m'allume il est là bas il ne sait
pas au juste un test qui va quitter là
bas ils sont cent douze à avoir perdu
leur emploi tous avaient des fonctions
au sein de l'organisation parmi eux ces
deux enseignants ils ont refusé de
renoncer à leur syndicat une condition
qui aurait été exigée selon eux par les
pouvoirs publics pour réintégrer leur
poste mais dieu aujourd'hui deux réunis
en syndicat qui veut réclamer manoir
c'est comme emprisonnement liberté
famille il faut que je n'ai jamais
commis un collectif d'avocats du
syndicat a déposé une requête auprès du
bureau international du travail afin
qu'ils recommandent la réintégration des
enseignants déchu de plus la personne
est édenté et la liberté sont met à mal
l'objectif c'est de décapiter le sexe la
liberté syndicale
comme droit fondamental de l'exercice du
droit de grève est une liberté
essentielle il faut le faire dans les
conditions en cas de départ à m'occuper
le droit de grève a été durcie depuis un
an et les nouveaux enseignants recrutés
le mois dernier ont dû signer un code de
bonne conduite où tout prosélytisme
syndicale est interdite par ailleurs
l'état d'urgence sanitaire qui limite
les rassemblements à 15 personnes est
toujours en vigueur au togo
une ong béninoise a récemment tenu son
septième à gros bouquin un stage pour
apprendre les méthodes et des techniques
de l'agriculture durable des pratiques
de plus en plus pertinente alors que
l'afrique de l'ouest est en proie au c
serait-ce effet face à sa prise pire
crise alimentaire depuis dix ans
un stage d'agriculture durable dont
jean-paul mangata ne compte pas louper
le moindre détail ce jeune congolais
espère y apprendre des nouvelles
techniques pour gérer sa plantation de
palmiers tout en respectant
l'environnement nous sommes notamment
dans la production de vin il faudra que
nous puissions contrôler le fruit que
nous utilisons pas ce que nous voulons
aujourd'hui nous voulons un monde une en
nous volant l'environnement qui hantait
dé préserver notre nature le stage
accueille une vingtaine de participants
venant du bénin de la rdc du nigeria et
du burkina faso après une session
d'exercices matinaux
le groupe passe la journée à apprendre
des nouvelles méthodes d'agriculture
durable comme identifié des produits
naturels pour remplacer les pesticides
outre la théorie les stagiaires doivent
aussi mettre la main à la pâte
beaucoup plus c'est le côté pratique des
feux sous la montre est quand même des
connaissances des compétences et aussi
des techniques
de retour dans son exploitation de
palmiers à kinshasa jean-paul mangata
n'a qu'une envie mettre ces nouvelles
connaissances en pratique il a développé
un moyen de récolter le vin de palme
sans avoir besoin d'abattre les arbres
quand la basse et pamiers pour avoir
rapidement devint notre environnement
est aussi détruit or nous ne faisons pas
l'abattage de pagnes donc c'est au
niveau du bourg jean apicale que
n'aurait qu'à autant notre vin alors que
l'afrique de l'ouest fait face à sa pire
crise alimentaire en dix ans le besoin
de développer une agriculture durable et
résistantes à la sécheresse se fait de
plus en plus pressants
alors vous savez les bienfaits de l'art
sont nombreux depuis de nombreuses
années des médecins s'en servent
d'ailleurs pour aider des patients
acquérir notamment en hôpital
psychiatrique c'est le cas du docteur
ibrahim à salif diop dakar une ville
vous le savez qui accueille une biennale
exceptionnelle du scot 19 juin le
renverser cher
en 2013 ibrahim salif diop se rend dans
une clinique psychiatrique de dakar
après avoir fait un burn-out depuis le
jeune homme y retourne régulièrement
pour participer à ces ateliers de
thérapie par l'art qui l'aident à
canaliser ses émotions il ya beaucoup de
choses qui étaient concentrées dans mon
esprit
ça dégage beaucoup d'énergie qu'ils
étaient négatifs
un sentiment partagé par de nombreux
patients pour qui ces sessions de
peinture hebdomadaire représente une
véritable thérapie depuis 2005 la
clinique moussa diop organise même une
exposition annuelle à l'occasion de la
biennale de dakar en plus d'offrir de la
visibilité à ces jeunes artistes
l'événement permet de s'attaquer au
tabou de la santé mentale toujours très
ancré au sénégal
ils n'ont plus confiance
déprimée médicaments comme si j'ai égaré
quoi on essaie de les reprendre notre
place dans la société
mais c'est pas facile pour nous là bien
là qu'une fenêtre c'est une fenêtre qui
permet de voir que derrière
l'image que nous avons ici au sénégal de
psychiatrie légale fou c'est pas sa
discipline relativement jeune l'art
thérapie se répandent de plus en plus au
sénégal une manière pour ces passions de
stimuler leur créativité de reprendre
confiance en eux mais surtout de
bousculer les idées reçues autour de la
psychiatrie et de la santé mentale
c'est ainsi que nous refermons ce
journal l'afrique merci à tous ceux qui
nous ont suivis de kinshasa à ouaga en
passant par j -p sur yvette rester avec
nous car l'actualité continue sur france
[Musique]